good morning believe nation today's
message is learned from everyone over to
you Nicki Minaj when people see there's
one person that's getting a lot of shine
or notoriety or whatever it makes them
feel unhappy with themselves I mean you
know the small-minded people feel
unhappy with themselves you know but the
but the intelligent girls just take you
know the things that they like from me
and my journey and they apply it to
their journey and and I think if I had
in my way that's what they'd all do I
mean everybody's not gonna like Nicki
Minaj you know I mean you know
everybody's not gonna like the way I
look and you know what I do but I think
if you're smart you would take from me
and and you know figure out why
everybody's talking about me and you
know I mean that would be the that would
be the smart thing to do and I think
they don't know how to express that
so they express it with anger and
jealousy and hatred and and then that
consumes them and you know and I'm still
here
when people ask me who some of my
mentors are I often get criticized for
some of the people that I pick you know
if I pick Howard Schultz from Starbucks
people are fine if I pick Walt Disney
people are fine I think Epogen Nene
people are fine but if I started talking
about Steve Jobs with Donald Trump or
Kanye West people start to freak out how
can you look up to these people you know
they treat people so poorly they make so
many bad decisions and the thing that
you need to understand is there is no
perfect version of you except what you
can create for yourself I don't look up
the Donald Trump and say I want to be
the next Donald Trump but I can learn
something from him and so can you to be
the best version of you regardless of if
we just look at Trump regardless of your
political affiliation you may love him
you may hate him doesn't matter there
are some things from him as an example
how he thinks big how he can communicate
that big think is what initially
attracted me to him it forces me to
think about how I can make my business
bigger whether you would vote for him or
not
can learn from him on how to think
bigger on how to make things clearer for
people to understand you look at Steve
Jobs you may think well the guy treated
his employees like crap he worked them
to the bone people couldn't work with
him well great
don't do that like why do you look at
the one negative thing that somebody has
and then say I can't learn anything from
this person
he built the most valuable company in
the world you can learn from him to make
you a better entrepreneur people look at
Kanye West and say he's done all these
crazy things right all these crazy
stunts and you know he's maybe too much
of a loudmouth great again don't do that
you've got a guy in Kanye who has won
more Grammy Awards than anybody at his
age is one of the best-selling artists
of all time he's in Time Magazine's Most
Influential People this guy has done a
lot you can learn from him even if you
hate him for me I would look to him as
somebody who is not afraid to express
himself how many times have you been
afraid to express yourself you had this
idea that you wanted to tell somebody
and you're too afraid to do it or you
had this thing you wanted to act on and
the little voices inside your head say
don't do that you can't do that you're
not good enough whatever that's what I
would tune in to the Kanye West inside
me and say I'm gonna go and do it I'm
gonna be unafraid of how people will
think of me or treat me I am going to do
it because my intention is good and that
doesn't mean I have to get up on stage
and take a ward away from Taylor Swift
to do something crazy but it can help
give me the courage to go out and do
something that I may not have had before
and so learning from all these people
they've had success you can learn from
them to make you the best version of
yourself and it just boggles my mind
that people would look at someone who's
achieved tons of success and they feel
that they want to get into and because
they've done a couple things that they
don't align with that everything else
they've done that maybe they can learn
from they immediately throw away there's
no one person that you can learn
everything from to help you become the
best version of yourself if you want to
launch a YouTube channel you might look
at mine you might say you might admire
the work ethic you might admire that
we're putting out three to four videos a
day and how much work goes into that in
the consistency of doing that for a long
period of time maybe you like that but
maybe you don't like my life I maybe you
don't like how I'm yelling at you maybe
you want to be a lot softer but you want
to be a lot more empathetic or whatever
it is something about me that you don't
like that's cool
instead of writing me off you can learn
from some of the things that we're doing
to make you the best youtuber that you
can be and so for people who hate on
Nicki Minaj great there may be some
things that she does that you just can't
stand who cares ignore that stuff if
there's ten rules that we do on her
maybe none of them are not relevant to
you but there's one that touches you a
little bit I've given quotes of Kanye as
an example and said hey this is a really
good quote use it I didn't say who the
name was oh that's a really good quote
and then they find out who said it they
go that's my name who said that people
attach so much stigma to the name and it
shocks me how much unwillingness they
have to learn from people just because
they've done some crazy things in their
life and so don't shut yourself off to
learning if you only put one person say
this is a guy or girl is gonna leave you
to success they're gonna let you down
because they're not perfect so you can
learn how to be a great husband or wife
from somebody you can learn how to be
great marketer from someone else you can
learn how to be great at raising capital
from somebody else take all these bits
and pieces from the people that have
done great things throw away everything
else and those will help you make the
best version of yourself so the question
of the day today is I'm curious what you
have learned from different people from
different entrepreneurs and different
people in your life what are some of the
characteristics maybe five things that
you've learned from five different
people that maybe recognize leave it in
the comments below super curious to see
what you guys mentioned thank you guys
so much for watching have an amazing day
ep2 believe and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot event
special